uh CNBC has a list of what it says are
the 10 worst states to live and work in
and this is a list that they update
every year and now we have the 2023
Edition so if you were thinking about
moving somewhere or you know a little
bit up in the air you didn't know where
you wanted to live
and you're waiting for guidance from
CNBC okay maybe you were talking with uh
maybe you were talking with your family
about moving and you said well we're not
gonna make any decisions
okay let's wait till CNBC tells us what
to do
so if you're in that camp then this is a
big moment for you they finally released
the the list they say they caught they
compile the list by the Numbers quote
unquote it's a strictly objective
determination based on the data
they say
now just to skip ahead to the twist
ending
the list of the worst states to live in
begins at number 10 with Florida one of
the most prosperous states in the
country it's one of the highest rates of
people migrating to it
and it ends with um as the worst state
of all number one on the list is Texas
again a prosperous state where hundreds
of thousands of people move to every
year
my own State Tennessee also makes the
list which is news to all the new
transplants that show up here every
single day
so it seems like all of the worst states
are exactly the states where most where
where the most people want to live it's
like the people the places where people
most want to live are all the worst
places
we're being told by CNBC
and another big coincidence here is that
um every state on the list is a red
state
I mean who could have seen that coming
they also have the list of the of the uh
of the best states to live and I believe
every state or certainly the vast
majority are blue States so
big big surprise there
but how do they so how do they determine
this you know how do they come to this
determination how do they say that
Florida really Florida is where it was
one of the worst states to live in the
country
Texas is the worst there's not a worse
place to live than Texas
well let's find out how they came up
with this uh ranking this is from the
article says each year as part of our
overall assessment of State business
climates
cnbc's America's top states for business
study considers how welcoming each state
is to workers and their families
Life Health and inclusion is one of the
study's 10 categories of competitiveness
and this year with the Nationwide worker
shortage so severe the category is
taking on increased importance in our
methodology we consider multiple quality
of life factors including crime rates
Environmental Quality and health care we
also look at the Quality and
availability of child care which is one
of the most important factors to get
parents back into the workforce
um
casting the widest possible net for
workers means not turning anyone away so
we consider inclusiveness in state laws
by measuring protections against
discrimination as well as voting rights
and with surveys showing a substantial
percentage of women considering abortion
restrictions when making a choice of
where to live in the wake of Supreme
Court overturn to Roe v Wade
Reproductive Rights are part of this
year's equation as well
okay so that's how it's just that's what
the list is the here are the most
conservative States also you shouldn't
live there because we don't like we
don't agree with conservatism
Grand Canyon University is an affordable
private Christian University located in
beautiful Phoenix Arizona praised for
its culture of community giving an
impact Grand Canyon University
integrates the free market system into
everything they do welcoming Christian
worldview perspectives into over 320
academic programs with more than 260 of
those programs online Grand Canyon
University's online programs are
designed to make earning your degree
easy and accessible no matter your age
or staging life so why wait if you're
ready to take your education to the next
level find your purpose at Grand Canyon
University visit
gcu.edu that's gcu.edu
if you're hiring you're probably dealing
with economic uncertainty and now more
than ever it's important to hire the
right people faster and more efficiently
to keep overall costs down thankfully
zip recruiter is a hiring partner who is
focused on you and your needs from
pricing to technology everything that
zip recruiter does is for you and what
works best for you right now you can try
them for free at ziprecruiter.com
smart technology identifies the best
matches for your job and lets you invite
candidates who really want to apply who
you really want to apply for your job
for other businesses can snag them up I
love how their pricing is really
straightforward you know what you paid
before posting your job so you can stick
to your budget with no surprises hire
the best with the help of a partner
who's all about you with zip recruiter
four out of five employers who post a
zip recruiter get a quality candidate
within day one just go to this exclusive
web address to try ZipRecruiter for free
ziprecruiter.com Walsh again that's
ziprecruiter.com
ZipRecruiter the smartest way to hire
um and so there's not a lot to say about
it this is just a farcical partisan list
except that
yeah because of course that's not what's
that's not what CNBC is directly saying
okay they're they're they are not
directly saying here are the most
conservative States we hate them because
we're liberal
they are trying to frame this as well
because they're conservative that means
it's a low quality of life nobody would
want to live there and it just shows how
the left and you know the media
specifically
they have really no concept
of what normal people
want out of life like what our
priorities are in life they have no
concept of that
because to them this there's nothing
farcical about this
they really think
that when most when your average family
is deciding where to move
that they're going to take into account
things like inclusiveness
a guy I can
I'm willing to bet and there's no way to
there's no way to to verify this
I'm willing to bet that this is that it
has never happened okay this
conversation has never happened where
you've got a nor just a normal
working class family
sitting around the dinner table and they
they got to move you know they know they
know they want to move from where they
are they want to go somewhere else
and they're talking about where they
could go next you know husband and wife
you got a spouse have this conversation
now this part has happened many many
times
I've been in these conversations with my
wife on multiple occasions as we've
moved around
um but here's the part that's never
happened
where husband or wife throws out of
state and someone and then the other one
responds how inclusive is it
where does it rank on the inclusivity
scale
oh no no oh no honey we can't move there
it's not inclusive enough
well yeah I mean look the crime rate is
low there are job opportunities there
are great schools for the kids uh you
know there's it's it's it's affordable
uh you know the living expenses are down
from where it is here here's all the
yeah but it's not inclusive enough the
inclusivity think of the Dei the Dei is
not there
that conversation has just never
happened
it just does not happen
and uh the media doesn't know is because
they don't understand anything about
human beings basically
this is funny though to read We're not
gonna go through the whole list but but
Florida I said came in number 10 on the
list so it's the 10th worst not the
worst but it's number 10.
here's what they say about Florida
um Florida Governor Rhonda Sanders hopes
to ride his war on woke to the White
House but it's not winning estate points
for quality of life supporters of the
state stop woke act which the Santa
signed into law in 2022 same protects
employees from diversity equity and
inclusion initiatives that DeSantis says
are toxic but many companies consider
Dei an economic imperative and courts
have struck down parts of the law
um the reason no no company thinks the
DI is an economic imperative many of
them do it many of them engage in this
it's a cultural imperative for them it's
a societal imperative
um it may it may in a in an indirect way
be it economic imperative uh because
they're worried about the ESG score
they're worried about the corporate
equality index
okay but this is not direct it's not
like if you if you uh put Dei as your
top concern that it's going to really
help your business directly
um no it's more that they're going to be
Financial penalties these are artificial
constructs put in place penalties they
put in place if you don't do this
so maybe in that sense it's an economic
imperative but it's all completely
artificial
uh the recent Supreme Court decision on
affirmative action and higher education
however is expected to lead to new legal
challenges related to Dei programs in
the corporate world Florida is one of
the most difficult states to vote in
wait let me read that again Florida is
one of the most difficult states to vote
in according to researchers at Northern
Illinois uh University
and so that's really why it's number 10
on the list and so and then they they uh
they give it a Life Health and inclusion
score of 129 out of 350 which is a D
grade it's only a d it's passing grade
though
you know in most schools I think that
counts as passing
um here are their strengths air quality
child care worker protections
sounds pretty good you know you got good
child care you can breathe the air
sounds like Necessities weaknesses
inclusiveness and Reproductive Rights
okay so the weaknesses are all the
things that no one gives a damn about
and then the strengths are the things
people actually care about got it
I am curious though Florida and I've
never lived in Florida so therefore I've
never voted in Florida but I would like
to know uh Florida is one of the most
difficult states to vote in how is it
difficult exactly
do you have to is there like
you have to scale a rock climbing wall
to get up to the polls
are the polls perched at the top of some
sort of uh precipice you have to climb
up to it
is that how it works
or do they have you know is it like a
ballot
on a on a on a kind of a a dart board
and you have to stand
10 yards back and throw your Dart and
hope that it hits the candidate you want
I mean that would count as difficult to
vote
but also make voting a lot more fun
um is that how it works in Florida I
mean I don't know maybe someone could
fill me in if those are if those are the
policies
but I'm pretty sure it doesn't work that
way and if you want to vote you could
just go and vote like anybody and it's
incredibly easy
pretty sure about that but I you know I
stand to be correct hey YouTube thanks
for listening to the show if you'd like
access to my full show with no ads you
should go to dailywire.com and use promo
code Walsh to get two months free on all
annual plans see you there